you're a single gentleman out in the
world you're looking you know talking
and you've been talking lately about
women that you find attractive you
recently professed your love for Dame
Helen Mirren yeah and and it got a lot
of attention take a picture of me right
here now what is it about Helen Mirren I
agree with you she's an incredibly
talented woman in a sexy one but you you
just went out of your way to say that's
that's the woman who you were most
interested in I just saw her in South of
France I was out there and she was just
looked at me and the this interesting
thing was going on and it's a different
thing like like Oh Hollywood is rich but
it's another thing right it's just like
this thing this confidence thing is
there from being tested improvement and
she looks at you like like she knows
she's sexy like I don't mind I'm like
you know husband's not far behind while
she's doing this she still has the habit
of looking at you that way and it's just
the way it is yeah do you think it's
possible you two could let's say the
husband tomorrow was in an zipline crash
it happens it's for a popular way of
getting around is it possible that you -
it could that ever happen you think of
it be a relationship there's some day as
long as he's alive I wouldn't say yes I
wouldn't say that's why he's alive well
he's alive yeah yeah yeah it's not right
right because you know what yeah I don't
want nobody waiting on me to get knocked
off yeah in a crash it's not the right
thing to do yeah okay I'll take care of
it
anything those test those are real quiet
you can drive right up
you